lo que los demás dice de los otros es lo
que creemos que somos
cuando algo veta hay que ver dibuja esta
guía hay que ver que desastres
esterillos los estados de algún modo
modelado baba reciente una especie de
tejido alrededor de nosotros que nos da
forma y pide descubrir lo que realmente
somos y lo que queremos hacer en la vida
los adultos consciente o
inconscientemente van proyectando sus
deseos particulares sobre sus hijos o
pupilos esto sucede en un determinado
núcleo familiar o escolar pero si lo
extendemos si extrapolamos a otros ya
tenemos un problema a escala social
esta es una encuesta sobre las
profesiones más deseadas por los niños y
niñas en españa en este año 2017 los
niños siguen queriendo ser futbolistas
famosos es decir éxito rápido fama
belleza riqueza juventud vigorosidad las
niñas en cambio en primer lugar desean
ser profesoras o doctoras pero también
muchas de ellas cantantes y actrices lo
que implica en esencia lo mismo que en
el caso de los niños
la maquinaria vital va poco a poco
cogiendo velocidad sin que nos demos
cuenta
puesto que los adultos intentan
transmitir sus deseos sobre los sobre
sus descendientes más cercanos de forma
inmediata y desde la infancia
pero cómo se produce ese
condicionamiento cuál es el mecanismo
más primitivo de control conductual sea
a nivel individual o colectivo el miedo
o lo que es lo mismo la sensación de
al gusto a provocada por la presencia de
un peligro real o peor aún y más
frecuente un peligro imaginario con
consecuencias directas nosotros mismos
como el estrés ansiedad
y seguridad la falta de motivación e
iniciativa se los quiere inculcar los
miedos a los cambios a volver 2 a salir
de nuestra zona de confort a simplemente
a perder el tiempo liberar 2 de todo
esto podría hacer que los demás perdiese
el control sobre los otros y que
surgiría con mayor frescura la capacidad
para pensar reflexionar tomar nuestras
propias decisiones
de esta manera se nos van a
estableciendo una serie de prejuicios
sobre los demás y la realidad misma que
aparece condicionada y deformada no os
dais cuenta de que todo a nuestro
alrededor es impermanente e
interdependiente y se halla en un
proceso de modificación constante y
continua el universo también se halla en
ese cambio y transformación constante
incluso nuestras células se renuevan
continuamente aunque según los últimos
estudios no lo hacen ni todas ni a la
vez abrir a que crecemos y avanzamos en
la vida la vida de vuestra vida la
velocidad de cada día va aumentado de
forma exponencial
se los presiona para conseguir el éxito
entendido como reconocimiento público
riqueza material
fava algo que los hace
ser extremadamente competitivos y a la
vez muy poco compasivos y cooperativos
esta carrera por alcanzarlo a toda costa
implica generar expectativas muy altas
dos otros mismos que puede crear
frustración si no se cumple de rápido y
de forma inmediata una de las
consecuencias más comunes de lo anterior
es que la sociedad actual produce
individuos muy bien formados
académicamente pero carentes de una
adecuada educación emocional sólida
incluso el propio sistema educativo
hasta ahora no le daba importancia a
este aspecto el mundo tecnológico en el
que vivimos
es sumamente acelerado produciéndose un
desfase entre estos avances tecnológicos
y el desarrollo emocional algo que ha
sido estudiado y demostrado por diversos
campos de la psiquiatría y de la
psicología entre ellos por el doctor
coleman el ser humano en su niñez
necesita mucho tiempo para crecer
emocionalmente sano
mucho tiempo quiere decir que no se
puede producir un desarrollo emocional
veloz y saltándose procesos se necesita
el tiempo suficiente para que le hacemos
las emociones se desenvuelvan y maduren
recuerdo que ya en 1998 durante una
conferencia científica a la que pude
asistir en la universidad complutense de
madrid carlos martínez alonso bioquímico
doctor en inmunología y en aquel momento
presidente del consejo superior de
investigaciones científicas pronosticaba
que las enfermedades de naturaleza
mental y psicológica iban a ser las
protagonistas a principios del siglo 21
fruto de esa aceleración estrés y
ansiedad en una sociedad tan competitiva
y tecnologizada como la contemporánea en
aquel momento todo esto parecía muy
lejano hoy en día ya no ya no tanto
y te trato contrarrestar esta tendencia
hacia una sociedad cada vez más
neurótico que opera a una velocidad de
estratosférica y sin pararse para
disfrutar la vida surge de nuestro
proyecto viajando a media luna con el
cual pretendemos y deseamos compartir
nuestros descubrimientos
experiencias vivencias fotografías
propuestas artísticas a raíz de nuestros
viajes este proyecto vital ha surgido
con duda primera travesía de larga
duración que hemos realizado en
bicicleta
y pre debe ser el prólogo de nuestro
viajar por el mundo pero de forma
sosegada reflexiva y si empresas
no es fácil salir adelante con un
proyecto de este tipo sin embargo lo
importante es quererlo y creerlo
en la primera etapa hemos ido
descubriendo y rescatando la esencia de
cada lugar para acercarla al público y
seguidores a través de nuestra
experiencia propia experiencia viajera y
filtro accesible y particular
este proyecto se retroalimenta de forma
autogestionada
de ambos cursos de fotografía charlas
exposiciones libros hay también trabajos
puntuales y locales en la mayoría de los
casos nos limitamos a replicar un papel
que nos marcan y como consecuencia de
ello nos sentimos alejados de nuestros
verdaderos deseos y esencia personal e
individual como seres humanos incluso
podemos llegar al final de nuestros días
sin habernos dado cuenta
lo hemos comprobado con nuestro proyecto
a través de nuestra propia experiencia
de forma empírica y también en personas
de diferente edad y generación de entre
todos estos casos recordamos al del
dueño de una fábrica artesanal de
chocolates en la zona sur de españa este
hombre
de cierta edad sostenía la cuarta o
quinta generación del negocio familiar
percibimos en sus comentarios y forma de
actuar que de alguna manera se había
visto obligado a continuar con esa
pesada tradición
al ver no que nosotros estábamos
desarrollando un proyecto tan libre y
abierto al mundo diseñado y construido
por nosotros mismos con una componente
de transformación vital continua nos
despidió con lágrimas en los ojos
seguramente arrepentido por haber
gastado toda su energía a los pies de
esa factoría y no haber reducido la
velocidad de su vida lo que le impidió
proyectarla de forma autónoma
pero como detener dos como reducir la
velocidad a la que todo sucede no cabe
duda que lo ideal sería a través de una
buena educación emocional desde nuestra
10 sin embargo lo más habitual es que
nos demos cuenta a través de alguna
experiencia traumática un cruce de
caminos vital una crisis profunda hace
un par de años cuando el experto de
alberte uno de los fotógrafos va a ser
conocidos a nivel mundial nos contó cómo
había llegado a serlo pues bien su
formación universitaria y profesión hice
el 20 y dote guía de la que ver con la
fotografía había acabado educ buffet
frío buffet de cuatro vistas de la
ciudad
de parís casi sin darse cuenta y con su
vida convertida según sus palabras el
relato gris y sin ilusiones
de pronto la muerte inesperada y
prematura de su hermano le hizo pensar
fue entonces cuando decidió
y ser completamente sincero consigo
mismo y dedicarse a ayuda de sus
verdaderas pasiones con toda su alma y
corazón
en momentos como éste surgen ante
nosotros dos opciones básicas una seguir
sufriendo siendo los espectadores de
nuestro propio drama
y otra actuar cogiendo las riendas de
nuestra vida y siendo los verdaderos
protagonistas de ella
nuestro proyecto también surgió en un
momento de en un punto de inflexión
vital para ambos al poco tiempo de
conocernos es un proyecto que nos está
permitiendo a raíz a través del proceso
de viajar de forma lenta y
autogestionada
detenernos y dejarnos sorprender por los
paisajes el contacto pausado con las
gentes su costumbre sus costumbres
tradiciones y cultura en el sentido más
amplio del término dedicarnos no sólo a
ver la vida sino a mirarla prestar
atención a todo lo que nos rodea y
darnos cuenta plenamente
de la realidad sin los filtros impuestos
por los demás a dejarnos sorprender
recuperando la mirada del niño que todos
llevamos potencialmente dentro
poniéndonos unas gafas unas nuevas gafas
con los que ver con las que ver la
realidad
de forma espontánea y fuera del papel
que se espera de nosotros desde el
principio tuvimos un gran apoyo por
parte de muchas personas y modestas
empresas en el norte de españa donde
troubs donde comenzamos dar forma a todo
este sueño parado esta veta al mismo
tiempo de tavo cierto distancia abierto
en algunas personas más cercanas a
nuestro entorno resultó ser algo
inesperado pero tampoco lo tenemos en
cuenta y hay un tipo de resentimiento
hacia nadie todo lo contrario más bien
empatía amor compasión etc o es que
quizá en aquél vogue todo entendieron ya
subieron este cambio de esquema vital
está determinada de nuestras vidas o tal
vez fue por miedo o por ver que los
salidos de los esquemas base
establecidos convencionales en la
sociedad de la que venimos al bajar la
velocidad de las acciones en nuestra
rutina viajera conseguimos de alguna
forma dilatar las dimensiones
temporales obteniendo la sensación y la
oportunidad de vivir una vida dentro de
otra vida
es nuestro derecho no es un delito tal y
como la sociedad nos intenta que nos
sintamos culpables hoy en día
recuerdo que durante mis años como
arquitecto de profesión como arquitecto
en españa'
creí que conocía perfectamente el país
cuando lo iba recorriendo con mi coche a
través de las carreteras principales
pero no fue hasta que decidimos cruzar
el país desde la frontera con francia
hasta lisboa durante cinco meses en
bicicleta cuando entendí que no conocían
nada en absoluto
viajar a la lenta velocidad de una
bicicleta cargada de equipaje te permite
ver todo lo que te rodea a cámara lenta
y lo que es más importante poder echar
el pie a tierra para detenerte en
cualquier momento y hablar con aquellas
personas que van surgiendo a tu paso
la bicicleta de estado del evento que te
ayude y acerca a los otros hemos
experimentado que la gente te ayuda más
que si viajas curvo chila o de cualquier
otra manera
creemos que es un componente que crea
confianza empatía acerca abierto desde
conseguir quitar arreglar una avería
gravísima adulta jr con maquinaria
pesada o familias que te abren las
puertas de sus casas o dos policías de
tráfico que te escolta y cortan la
circulación de vehículos en una gran
ciudad para sacarte del peligro al salir
de la rutina de una vida más
convencional pautada y acelerada hay que
saber adaptarse a esa vasta
disponibilidad de tiempo
y ser flexibles a los cambios que se nos
presentan de forma inesperada y
convertir la incertidumbre en nuestra
aliada
no puedo ser el guión de de vuestra vida
es algo lo que nos debe alimentar
colgadas de vivirla dado dos la votación
para que cada día sea proyectado y
modelado de forma diferente infinita
nosotros mismos una gran bandera para
hacer coherente con la esencia cambiante
y universal de la vida quizá a nuestro
paso por el mundo sea como como un
suspiro dentro del tiempo del universo
pero todos debemos tener miedo a
perderlo perder el tiempo es ganar la
vida muchas gracias y en wii de marzo